Welcome to week four in the robot vision project.
Just to summarize so far, we've taken an image
of our robotic vision worksheet and we've
segmented the objects into their particular colours.
The object for this week is to now classify
these 2D objects in their shape and size;
so we have circles, squares and triangles.
I've written a function in MATLAB that allows
me to do this, so let's take a look at the
output of this week.
So in MATLAB here I have four different variables;
the first is img, which is my R robotic vision
worksheet image, and the remaining three variables
are the outputs of what I showed you last
week.
So I have r2d, g2d and b2d. And these are
the thresholded binary images, which contain
the 2D objects, shapes in either the red channel,
green channel or the blue channel. So for
this week, what I'd like you to do is make
a function called "getShape".
Now how getShape works is that you parse it
some parameters and then it will return a
toolbox blob object, which is associated to
the 2D object that you're trying to find.
So let's go through some examples of how to
use this function. So say I'd like to find
the small red square, then I can call a function
that I've made, called getShape and my function
here takes in three inputs; the first is the
binary or logical image that I got from my
getColour function from last week.
So because I'm trying to find a red square,
I'm going to parse in my red binary image.
The next input is the particular shape I'm
trying to find, so either a square, circle
or a triangle, so I'm trying to find a square,
and then the final input is the size that
I'm after, or the bulk. So if I'm trying to
find a small or a large square.
Okay, so that function is then going to go
into the image and try and find a small square.
And then if I look at the toolbox blob object
that it's returned, you can see that it's
returned one blob and that will be the small
red square. And to check that you can use
another toolbox function, which is the plot_box
associated with the toolbox blob.
And then if we execute that and we go back
to our image, you can see that a blue square
has been drawn over my red square, so there's
two red squares in the robotic vision worksheet,
as you can see here and the small one has
been highlighted.
Okay, so let's do another example; let's say
we're trying to find a small green circle.
So small, green, circle.
So I call my function getShape again, but
this time because I'm trying to find a green,
I parse in my green thresholded image and
I'm trying to find a circle and we're trying
to find the small one.
Okay and then I can use plot_box again, and
then if I go back to the image you can see
that there are two green circles on the robotic vision worksheet and the small one has been highlighted.
So that's the goal for you guys to do this
week; is to make a function similar to what
I've done with getShape, that allows you to classify the 2D objects, in terms of a shape and a size.